how can buying property in coventry
basingstoke and milton keynes possibly
help people living in mid-suffolk and
baby
back in 2017
baber and mid-suffolk district councils
created sifco limited a commercial
property investment company designed
purely to generate money to be
reinvested in council services
the councils borrowed 50 million pounds
each and lent it to cifco so cifco could
buy a portfolio of properties
sifco now manages this portfolio
collecting rent from its tenants
it then pays the councils more than
enough to pay back their loan repayments
plus money on top for the councils to
reinvest in services and projects such
as helping the recovery of the local
economy supporting communities and
combating climate change so how's it
performing so far sifko has brought in
more than five million pounds in extra
income for baber and mid-suffolk and
more than two million of that was during
2020 2021 despite the impact of covet
that's all money that we can use to
support our districts
but hasn't sifko made massive losses
there were always costs involved in
buying property and when you invest 100
million pounds you can expect fees and
stamp duty to also add up to millions
we've also seen the value of some
properties fall
meaning cifco has recorded a 4.5 million
pound loss for 2020 2021
but this is what's known as a paper loss
because it would only happen if we sold
the whole portfolio tomorrow and we
won't be doing that the portfolio is a
long-term legacy for residents
generating income for years to come with
sifko gradually repaying the loan so
these properties will ultimately be
owned debt free by baber and mid-suffolk
district councils
but isn't this risky
cifco was careful about which properties
it brought
making sure there was a mix of
industrial commercial and retail across
the uk to reduce the impact of any
disaster across any particular sector or
area
sifko's performance goes through
rigorous regular scrutiny by elected
councillors and the company needs the
agreement of both councils each year to
carry out its plans for the next 12
months
these debates and votes are live
streamed for everyone to see
sifko's accounts are independently
audited and the details of the full
portfolio and quarterly statistics are
all publicly available on cifco's
website
so
you can be sure that the councils are
keeping a close eye on their investments
and that the professionals at sifko as
well as the external experts who advise
them are making sure these properties
continue to bring in money for baber and
mid-suffix communities for many years to
come